today's scenario what is the relevance
of organic food yeah
yeah see uh whether you call it as
organic there are different names to
organic you know the organic biodynamic
parma culture sahaja rishi natural
agriculture all lot of names under
various
you know
name categories it is being practiced
but you ask me whether what is the
relevance of organic why are we talking
today the relevance of organic we know
today that there are large scale
problems with current agricultural
practices
they
everybody knows that they simply cannot
sustain that we cannot live with toxic
residues both into our body out there in
the rivers and oceans and the large
scale input
that agriculture today consumes take for
example
no if i have to say the relevance of
organic or natural forming or more
eco-friendly forming
then we should know what is the problem
with the current system
the current system today we have is take
for example energy
now
in order to get one calorie we are talk
today talking about consuming spending
10 calories to produce one calorie of
food if you take a frozen green peas
they talk something like 15 calorie to
deliver one calorie
this is unsustainable system
and you say for example this this is
it's like uh
burning the house to get rid of a mouse
you know it just cannot sustain you
cannot be spending your body we know the
second law of thermodynamics that energy
can neither be created nor destroyed
okay but it can it can be
but at the same time you can convert
this one good form into another bad form
that's the problem
so whether the current system is
sustainable is a serious serious
question take for example shrimp
today to produce one kg of shrimp and to
export it to united states of america we
have to feed 4 kg of sea fish
is that the way to do it
should you be you know why not eat the
seafish itself why produce this exotic
variety and sell it to the united states
of america on foreign exchange at the
cost or the capital cost of natural
resources
and then you see
in our production system today
we have large number of pesticides large
number of fungicides
okay and
herbicide so large number of them you
know in order to produce this food we
have you know we have to dump large
quantity of chemicals
does it really help does it really today
if you talk about india we are almost
using 20 000 crore worth of pesticides
and harvard is exported of course there
people use also pesticides within the
household but the system is riddled with
all these toxicities take for example
antibiotics
why are antibiotics floating antibiotics
are not supposed to be given for
weight gain you know meat production
they are supposed to be used for
treating diseases but today we have they
say you have antibiotic resistant genes
even in antarctica see when you use
antibiotic in the animal farming in the
current system so what happens you
you okay you get the residues of it the
beet milk and egg and all that but then
this waste goes as manure to form to
grow fruits and vegetables
so you have problem of antibiotic
resistance going across and bacterias
they are very clever
they also transfer their
antibiotic resistant gene horizontally
across others other other microbes so
you have a serious problem of anti
antibiotic resistant genes emerging
across the world so i would say that
today organic holds water and is
relevant because
in organic you have to do polyculture
you can't do monoculture
there may be wrong kind of organic
agriculture in the poly houses and all
kinds of things not that you shouldn't
do it in the poly house but
organic is embedded in polyculture
organic mean that you will have to bring
back the number of
a sturdy and hardy variety of seeds and
breeds that have gone into the oblivion
bring them back into the system they
have the natural immunity
some of them can grow without seed take
for example a hybrid cow and a native
breeds of cow and what kind of input you
need for the hybrid varieties where
yield alone is the criteria look at the
natural you see typically they talk
about the natural farming in the chicken
farming in the rural countryside second
farming is you use a chicken
sorry the kitchen waste and feed the
chicken and get the chicken back into
the kitchen that's a natural farming
that's a sustainable system you don't
build a house
a concrete house for the chicken and
feed the corn and soya grown in the
amazon forest so how do you do what
you're conforming
you know this just defeats the common
sense that animal form if you take
animal farming was always a part and
parcel of the human farming they were
complementing each other you get the
grain grass goes to animals today you
grow the grain for animals and the
leftover oil comes to human beings
so today the byproducts of animal
feeding comes to human beings so this is
not you know sustainable this is not
very healthy today we talked about
global warming today we talk about
ecological damage we talk about sixth
mass extinction we talk about
islands of dead dead oceans in the in
this in the in the ocean dead oceans is
where nothing grows because too much of
nitrates from the aggregate fertilizers
leeching into the ocean and then
algal growth and then there is no oxygen
available
so the fishes die the marine life you
know is that
great it's a threat to marine life so
you have you know it's not farming is
not within the four walls it's done in
the open environment it is done in the
open ecology and what kind of impact it
has as as a sensible human beings we
know that we share this world with other
beings and the catalogued species on
this earth are just about 10 million but
they say uncatalogued could be 100
million
that is why it is said that we need to
preserve this world in whatever you do
particularly agriculture because it is
done in the open environment so that you
preserve the nature so one day you will
start appreciating how ignorant foods we
want
but ragu they say that organic food is
very expensive which middle class can't
afford like what do you have to say
about this but you see in my opinion
they always ask this question counter
question what is the real cost of cheap
food if you consume large quantities of
sugars and fat and the refined foods
that we all consume and we end up
spending our money for the diabetes and
sugar and and
heart health
today you know who says that once
diabetic strikes at the age of 40 it
costs you 10 lakh rupees
so are you so it's very good but you do
because it treats the economy and all
that pharmaceutical companies grow
hospitals grow and all that so what is
the cost of the real food if you had to
eat healthy food i know
unfortunately organic today is expensive
almost 30 percent more
but i would say
if you are cold saving water preserving
ecology
insect population or the microbial
population if your production system has
not eliminated and decimated those
systems until you produce a cheap food
then you ask further questions
they see the typically current practices
produce heap and sell cheap you know
that's the kind of agriculture
production system you have but what is
the real cost of your food if you
produce nutritious food if you prod or
diverse food if you have varieties of
food if it is production is slightly
less
then you if you pay more because you
have saved water because you see for
cleaning environment how much are we
spending today
see the government of india last year
sanctioned 3000 crore to clean pesticide
in river waters
is that the way can we clean up the air
water soil can you clean up all that
we cannot clean up
this is a very dynamic emerging
ecosystem
you cannot clean it up but you must
eliminate how can you prevent so in my
opinion see organic farming is a is a
thought intensive science
in chemical forming in my opinion you
have a narrow constructor called
causative you have a pest problem use a
pesticide you have a soil problem you
use a fertilizer you use a problem use
this you are not getting slave take a
sleeping tablet so this is a kind of a
problem and solution called you know
kind of a match but i find problem with
that match so i i would say that the
organic farming
can definitely feed the world if you
follow the nutrition per acre and you
know maintain the ecology environment
and all that all said and done today we
produce something like 2600 million tons
of food
which if you calculate is more than
enough to be feed seven billion people
why are hung one one billion people
hundred core people are hungry and
malnourished
why are 125 crore people are overfed and
obese
so it is not the production that the
product we have problem with but the
distribution but the diversity and all
that and all said and done today you
take for example
government
across the world they subsidize chemical
forming
if you put poison you are subsidized if
you don't put you save the nature and
give you a healthy food
there is no incentive
and people ask why is it more costly
people don't understand the hidden cost
of food production do you know there is
one connection many well-known people
are saying that when you subsidize wrong
food you end up being obese
you don't see the link apparently you
don't see the link but let's say i
subsidize urea and i subsidize one
single variety of rice i subsidize
processing i give you white rice and you
eat it and you become sick so i'm saying
and then i subsidize hospital care i
subsidize insurance look at the economy
we run our own diseases
should we not think of you know how to
how to be preventive in diseases how to
be proactive
so
there is enough food and food can be
take for example india which is 60 is
dry land you can't use fertilizers
pesticide in dry land but india has
forgotten dry land and we import 60 000
crore worth of oil from
south america and malaysia
is a massive quantity of oil we don't
grow oil seeds in this country and if we
can tackle the dry landforming which is
possible to do in organically
you know the echo divers you know
ecologically fragile regions
so i see if you see what we have done is
in the current economic system we
exclude ecology and social cost
they say what is the cost of pollination
by bees the fao says about
300 billion dollar
there's a cost of pollination but we
don't account for it that is why you
always miss the wood for trees people
ask that is why it is sad that you know
people we have great answers but
unfortunately for wrong questions in our
production
you know system today
so ragu now tell me how difficult is it
in india to do organic farming
is it easy or is very difficult right
now at this situation i would say there
are a lot of community knowledge
when it comes to human health when it
comes to agriculture when it comes to
animal husbandry how do todas you know
the tribes in nilgiris take care of
buffalos they know better than a doctor
there
do they not have do don't they know how
to take care of animal health they know
i have a book called wild health by
cindy she stole how do animals take care
of their health
no i'm not saying you know you don't
want science and
technology but you also see that
something is working already
something is already working
you see the natural forming and you know
without see if i can grow food in a
complementary way
typically it is like this why does a
pest emerge when there is monoculture
when there is water logging when i have
used when
soil fertility is connected to pest
emergence
suppose i have a beautiful manure of
microbe in the soil and the good humus
in the soil higher carbon content in the
soil then the best emergence is very
less
so the deeper connection in nature
see don't you have a narrow construct
deeper connection in nature then you say
the pest is not because the by pest
itself but because you provided a
conducive environment for the best to
emerge and first to become more potent
you use pesticides and more pesticides
and they become more potent then you had
to genetically modified food in order to
resist the uh pest
so it is
typically you know it is said that it's
a treadmill technology where you know
you you keep moving but you don't move
at all it's like a sea waves they move
but they don't move away
they're there but you always make to
made to feel that it is progress is
happening development is happening but
all said and done i don't want to eat
food written riddled with poisons and
you know pesticides and antibiotics i
want to eat a healthy food
i don't want to subject myself i'm not a
guinea pig
i want to be healthy i want to be happy
or eat natural food i want to tear
diverse variety of food so that is what
i think you whether you call it organic
biodynamic at all i think the science
ecology was never considered as a
science
unfortunately even evo wilson the man
who popularized you know the ecological
concept within the in the harvard his
department was shut down
where they simply did this is not
science
science is show me
you produce something
you give me a plus b is equal to c plus
d do you show me something but in
ecology you can't show like that there
are complex connections
so that is why in order to preserve
ecology and you know diversity health
and without all these toxic residues
that come to us
and that's a threat to other beings also
so that is where i feel when you give
any name to organic you give biodynamics
any name you call it but it is high time
we thought that can our food be safe
see they see the current world revolves
around three things
insecurity uncertainty and unsafety what
uh sigmund bowman will known sociologist
calls as the trinity of the modern world
treaty of honor is unsafety insecurity
and uncertainty that's the problem
and in the production system he also
says that we create waste and one of the
waste is human beings themselves there
are waste products out of the economic
system so i think we need to go back to
eco technology sustainable farming
less input take for example urea today
in the beginning we gave one kg of urea
for 25 kg of food grain today 1 kg of
area urea yields only 7 kg of grain
imagine 30 million tons of area urea for
250 million tons of food grain
and it is you see the ratio is declining
year over year i think you will land up
using uh one kg of fertilizer for half
kg of grain
is that sustainable serious question or
i must also tell you that the phosphorus
for example that we make dap and
phosphorous compounds to feed the
agriculture the phosphorus is mind
and the nature and many of the best
science journals peer review journals
say that at the current rate of
phosphorus mining it would last about
125 years
and you don't want the agriculture to
continue after that
what do you do
if you exhaust your minds
is there no other way we can grow food
so the input dependent intensive input
dependent
uh you know technological fixes do not
help us in the long run you need science
you need deeper science larger science
to understand all this understand the
human nutrition requirement biodiversity
requirement ecological requirement and
you all forming today for example wes
jackson a brilliant guy in the us the
land institute he talks about perennial
crops
you need not even plow every day every
year and plant and replant and
transplant and all that can you have
perennial
agriculture without the imports i mean
that's something seriously we should but
of course when you when you do something
when you do an agriculture without the
input it doesn't help the pharmaceutical
industry it doesn't help the chemical
industry it doesn't help the government
it doesn't help the subsidy it doesn't
help anybody so raghu one last question
how healthy healthy is organic food yeah
see if you ask how healthy i should ask
you is if you think that the little bit
of pesticide and antibiotics are okay
then it is not so healthy
uh if you think that um
you know more nutrients and
phytochemicals and antioxidants are not
all that important then it's no
different there is no difference so you
see where you should look at this see if
you look if you do the comparison
based on this narrow nutrition concept
of carbohydrate protein fat and all that
you will know you may not see much
difference but if you look at the amino
acids if you look at the phytonutrient
profile
if you look at the harm the pesticides
and antibiotic residues can do to your
human health you see a world of
difference but you see the problem you
see matt ridley who wrote this famous
book called rational optimus where he
says that in the
high yield era
we have produced large quantity of
starch which is sugary which he says
that there is more amylopectin and
lesser formylose which means that it
floods your blood
quickly what you eat floats your blood
quickly and you don't spend the energy
it lands up being stored as fat
so there is a serious problem you see
the very production system you have
agriculture scientists are disconnected
from nutritional aspect nutritional
scientists are disconnected from
something else that is always a
disconnected but if you see
the to to see the real value you should
be able to connect this way that
when i give see we all have to derive 60
of starch for our energy because the
blood and brain uses only starches
the energy source but what kind of
starch are you eating high in you know
this sugary starch or complex star
starch then you see the difference
a cow that walks a lot and eats
diversity of plant you will have better
nutrition in the milk you will have
higher omega-3 fatty acid
than a cow that is always tied to its
shed and you know just change from one
shed to another shed you will see a
difference in the milk milk quality so i
would say that the the difference that
you will have to see uh you know if you
really see they say that's why you know
oscar wilde's famous statement that we
today the modern a knows the price of
everything but the value of nothing
so you will have to discriminate this
way then you see the real change as i
said you know that there are all large
number of unknown compounds
unknown compound don't take the current
yardstick and judge and decide
you know that's why see we have one lakh
variety of rice but if you see the
nutrition value of indian foods or the
nutrition table of the us fda and many
of the fao tables you give you get one
table for rice
are they all same
no they are not same
you have different varieties of rice
different they they speak in different
colors
size shape
yield whole lot of difference you see
but nutritionally they are same how can
they be same
that's why you know rumi the great sufi
saint said if you call me a shia sunni
hindu muslim christian and putting me
put me into any box that will be your
coughing yeah so you must be able it's
not that you know you this it's not that
that the world changes but you need to
develop a new eye to see this
because our current
scientific eye with which we see
there is a flaw in it there's a
fundamental flaw in it
because you simply look at the protein
fat and all that you don't care what
kind of starch you don't care whether it
is sugary you don't care whether there
are phytochemicals whether antioxidant
forget this is a good part of it the
nutrition part of it what about the bad
part of it bad part of it
am i okay with antibiotic residue
am i okay with pesticide residue am i
okay with growth hormones in the animal
farming and the agriculture farming am i
okay with early flowering chemicals am i
okay with artificial ripeness
am i okay with all that i want my fruit
to be natural and good so that i really
enjoy my food
you